from the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in
Los Angeles California it's the 51st
annual Academy Awards
now we're in the plaza of the Dorothy
Chandler Pavilion of the Music Center in
Los Angeles California where crowds have
been gathering since early morning to
witness the arrival the most glamorous
names in the movie industry
this is booster
this is his first nomination for coming
home Supporting Actor
here is
Marsha Mason nominee last year for Best
Actress and Neil Simon nominee for a
screenplay
here comes telly savalas nominee
gary busey nominee for the Buddy Holly
story Robin Williams Sports Award is
about to start a new movie for Popeye
and dianne.kennett nominee for
Supporting Actress in heaven can wait
here is Christopher Reeve Superman the
latest movie Idol and Margot Kidder Lois
Lane and Superman one of the presenters
tonight is Jake Kolber
Oh
for the best actor for coming home
john-boy
Marvin Wagner Robert Wagner in Beverly
would
Supporting Actress in the Jerry
conversely for first-time nominee for
Supporting Actress an Audrey Hepburn
warmer weather presenter tonight of a
special award and here is Lord Lord
Celebi a nominee also he presented a
special honorary award from the Academy
tonight and this is Jane Fonda's actress
nominees for coming home
the 51st annual Academy Awards with a
galaxy of stars it sent with the gallery
stars Lauren Bacall Robby Benson ray
Bolger Debby Boone jewel winner George
Burns
Dyan Cannon James Coburn Francis Coppola
Sammy Davis jr. Dom DeLuise Richard
Dreyfuss
Mia Farrow Cary Grant doc Haley Audrey
Hepburn
Shirley Jones movie killer
Christmas Jefferson Keith Lawrence
paralympic Ali MacGraw
shirley maclaine
Barry Manilow Dean Martin Steve Martin
Johnny Mathis Olivia newton-john's
get movin Ginger Rogers Diana Ross tell
me Cevallos Butchie
the controller
Maggie Smith Maureen Stapleton Donna
Summer
Danny Thomas Shep Pawlenty tomboys John
Wayne
look out well Paul Williams Robin
Williams David L Wofford Natalie was an
ostrich master Cervantes Johnny Carson
the overture featuring music from the
[ __ ] nominated original scores will be
performed by a 100 piece ensemble known
as the orchestra Alan Ferguson
conducting
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
mr. Howard W Potts
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the 51st Academy Awards
tonight oscar has his second 50 years
starting and to help us celebrate this
event there are over 50 stars a range in
age from 8 to 83 they represent
Hollywood's past its present and most
importantly its future as in the past we
again joined together to Ono achievement
and excellence in the film industry and
that excellence Karasu a choice
remembered of that I'm sorry the master
of ceremonies tonight a critic recently
described him as a national treasure and
we share that opinion the Academy is
proud to welcome mr. Johnny Carson
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
Howard thank you for the very flattering
remarks before we begin tonight ladies
and gentlemen I would like to say for
the record that I am in favor of using
more American Indians and other
minorities and motion pictures I am
against polluting the oceans of the
world I'm for every nationality having
its own homeland I'm against whacking
baby seals on the head and I'm for
saving the whales
thank you I've never received a
squatting ovation before I as you all
know by now this is the 51st annual
Academy Awards two hours of sparkling
entertainment spread out over a four
hour show
I know I think the Academy can be very
proud tonight that this program is being
beamed via satellite right at this
moment 254 countries throughout the
world and 350 million people this
program is also being broadcast to South
America in the in that way the former
executives and accountants that the
studios will be able to catch part of
the show
yes interesting sidelight it's also be
singing in the oil-producing or the OPEC
nations this year but this year ABC is
added on a 9% increase for the
television rights in those countries we
figured fair was fair I know I was just
thinking I wonder if Jerry Brown and
Linda Ronstadt are watching from the
Kenya Holiday Inn
Hey I doubt it is a dollar extra for TV
in the room
now a lot of people who come to these
Affairs try to act blase and I'll have
to be very honest with you I am very
thrilled to stand up here tonight and
gaze out on this glorious throng of
beautiful people I see a lot of new
faces especially on the old faces
but I think all you have to do ladies
and gentlemen is take a casual glance
around this audience tonight you realize
the the elite of the film world has
turned out for this memorable occasion I
have not seen so many major motion
picture star has gathered together in
one place since the last audition for a
television commercial as a matter of
fact that's why Marlon Brando is not
here tonight Marlins on a Navajo
Reservation filming a Missoula
commercial Marlin calls it maize now I
think everybody has pretty much agreed
that the quality of pictures nominated
this year in the category the best is
outstanding and I don't want to take any
favorites but to me heaven can wait was
an unusual picture for two reasons
first of all it was a real fantasy about
Warren Beatty not being able to find a
body he could use
and the other reason was the plot the
plot was intriguing heaven can wait
showed it might be possible for someone
to die and come back to life a notion
which scares the hell out of Christina
Crawford
and I think the variety of music up this
year is uh is wonderful you might be
thrilled to know I just heard this
afternoon that one of the nominated
songs this year are ready to take a
chance again
has just been selected as the theme song
by the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
perhaps the biggest change in motion
pictures at least since I've been a kid
isn't in their maturity movies have
really grown up since the early days of
censorship motion pictures today tackled
controversial themes they're not afraid
to portray nudity and very often they
show explicit sex but the only thing
left to the imagination is how much
money the studio really made on the
picture
that joke in Bulgaria I think will do a
little better though the you know the
plots of change you see well I suppose
today's pictures are much more liberal
than when I was a kid because I remember
going to the movies
and every time they showed two people
about to become intimate on the movie
screen they would cut away two giant
waves pounding the shore and for years I
thought for play led to drowning
you see in those days we always knew how
the romantic pictures were gonna turn
out but today is Hollywood formula is
boy meets girl boy loses girl girl Sue's
boy for half of everything mr. Chu
naughty please go right [ __ ] Hollywood
take on that's here damn Jake D'Amelio
Jo Jo to kneel on site before could eat
Incheon sake fire dagwon see loser you
got lamb type poor Todd thought to go
away now I realize that means absolutely
nothing to you but right now
vice-premier Deng Xiaoping in China is
hysterical
I thought I should do one
person-to-person joke for the new
diplomatic recognition those of you here
tonight of toil in Hollywood for a
number of years realized that an actor's
life today is probably a little better
in the old days the major studios were
in charge they had all the stars under
contract told you what picture to make
what studio to make it for and how much
you'd be paid in those days the big
studios were all powerful as a matter of
fact Jack Beutel and Jane Russell still
Oh RKO v Pictures Universal has just
announced its newest disaster film
coming out called Airport 1980 and I
want to tell you this is a harrowing
epoch in which passengers aboard a 747
are held hostage for two weeks while a
mad man keeps rerunning the in-flight
movie moment by moment
do you realize why we're all here having
a good time Woody Allen is sitting home
watching his sneakers go through the
spin cycle it's been a big year for
directors named Allen
Irwin Allen gave us a movie about bees
and Woody Allen gave us a movie about
wasps now if you know ladies and
gentlemen there has been some criticism
of the Academy and especially of this
telecast that it is rather a frivolous
cheap commercial exploitation that is
not true and I will discuss this in
greater detail following the swimsuit
competition between Laurence Olivier and
Jon Voight I want to thank the Academy
for inviting me to be your host this
evening I hope you're all relaxed now so
let's settle back and all enjoy the
program together thank you